Kourtney Kardashian packing on the PDA  with her new man  while ex Scott Disick parties in Miami  [Music]  check out Courtney hand-in-hand with her  beau Eunice Benjamin in France over the  weekend on Sunday the 38 year old  reality star was spotted taking a sweet  stroll with the 23 year old model around  the French Riviera cork a looked happier  than ever walking around the city she  posted this pic posing in a photo booth  captioned new phone who dis meanwhile  Scott is living it up in Miami with his  close pals enjoying the yacht life a  source close to Kourtney told ET she  isn't losing any sleep over Scott's  behavior but she does love him adding  she's worried this won't ever stop and  hopes he gets the help he needs it's not  really fair for me to feel that way I  don't want you to have to feel anxious  or guilty  [Music]  you